look at this
rang the bell at the New York Stock
Exchange Friday morning
oh look at this note after Gary rang the
bell the market dropped 300 points
that's right he killed the market yeah
people saw him
what was going on uh you rang the bell
yeah yeah so I'm working with an
organization that I work with every year
and they do like a giving day like you
know for charity so for Life beat I do
the stuff and and they donate money to
lifebeat so uh people want to see you
ring the bell I guess yours me and
Charles Oakley from the Knicks and the
guy that runs the organization so yeah
it was Charles Oakley like who are you
like what what do you dude Howard we got
to take pictures it's it's I'm like his
pet you know what I mean like I'm like
Friday yes I mean like I think he could
lift me up and just throw me out the
window and what do you think scared the
the market to go down 300 points was it
the teeth I mean maybe they said Jesus
it's going to be a run on Ivory or
something look at what's happened to the
people who ring the bell at the stock
exchange it's woo Robin you're so right
like there's pictures up it's like
Michael Jordan and I think like Prince
Charles and then you know but listen
they got to do it they got to do it 365
days a year do it every day that's right
sometimes I slip in I'd be really upset
if I was Charles Oakley and they were
like listen Mr Oakley you're it's not
enough for you know you're just a New
Yorker
you need Gary delevante from the Howard
Stern Show and he's like Gary de la
banke what the [ __ ] is that he's
probably like um you know Mr open in my
life yeah
and Mr Oakley goes well I thought I was
coming here to ring the bell by myself I
mean ringing the bell isn't exactly the
height of show business but okay who is
this guy with the teeth and everything
and they go um he's some Gary de la
bonke and they go he goes well what does
he do he hosts the wrap-up show
wait a minute he might have even said
who did he play for yeah yeah like he's
kind of short but did he play division
one college Bob
of course they got Gary's name wrong
they came close though
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm both there from Wall Street as in
New York Stock Exchange welcome
CIBC Capital markets Vice chair and
managing director Eric Price executive
producer of the Howard Stern Show Gary
dellabate and NBA All-Star Charles
Oakley bringing today's opening bell
very good Gary congratulations on your
triumphant uh it was fun